Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 2nd,
2015 oh my God.
It's no fair.
You know,
the greatest holiday of the year for me
is what?
Thanksgiving.
I like it.
It's family.
You get to eat.
What about flag day?
That's a good one,
isn't it?
Why don't you go underground support that indie band,
right?
They could do that.
Labor days.
Another good one.
Okay.
A blueberry pancake day or whatever the fuck it was that time when I was in
Atlanta,
I would tell you guys that story.
I wanted to do morning TV,
the worst fucking thing a comedian can ever do.
It doesn't sell one fucking ticket.
You know,
watch his morning TV.
Fucking a stay at home moms.
You know,
you know those in,
in the,
in those awful stay at home moms.
Oh cool.
Stay at home.
Mom probably pops in a good movie or some shit like that.
But those,
you know,
those ones that talk to kids like they're fucking morons and they do it.
Like,
you know it's bad enough when the kids really little,
but when they're like six years old and they're still going like
they do that fucking up and down talking with like their eyes really fucking
open eyebrows way up.
Huh?
Woo.
You just want to fucking slap him in the back of the head like what are you
doing and do me a favor.
Don't talk to my dog like that.
Cause you're going to freak her out and she's going to go for your throat.
All she's going to hear is heightened excitement and she's going to be thinking
someone's going to beat the shit out of her again like [inaudible] or whoever
the fuck did it to her before I got her.
Isn't that right?
Cleal Huh?
She's over there already sleeping.
There's fucking dog slept for Aki.
Diem hours last night.
Right?
Right next to me.
By the way,
I hadn't seen her in like two weeks.
So I was watching the Casey met game and I actually fell asleep before the end
of it.
I was so fucking tired.
And then of course,
I wake up afterwards and I see Casey celebrating.
By the way,
congratulations to Kansas City,
my condolence to mets fans,
uh,
just to fucking great teams.
And it was so great to see,
you know,
not to see Yankees,
red sox car knows giants,
the fucking people who have been in it.
It's nice to see new blood.
Um,
so anyways,
I'm sitting in,
I'm trying to fucking see the highlight and I'm just sitting there and my dog
likes this.
My dog is a master like Cutler.
The thing is all away,
like legs tucked underneath and it's fucking guts.
It's head right on my chest,
right with its muzzle,
almost like just like staring at me and it's snoring.
So I don't want to wake the thing up.
And I'm sitting there and the remotes on the other side of my fucking dog and
I'm like,
I can't wait this thing up.
And I'm sitting there waiting for a fucking highlight.
And they got this guy
who's just standing there going on and on and on and on and on and on and on
about the fucking game about what happened and blah,
blah,
blah.
It's like,
show a fucking highlight.
You jerk off.
What are you,
the president given some fucking state of the union thing.
So many fucking ESPN shows now.
I've just too fucking people sitting there,
standing there,
walking around,
talk and talk and talk it to death.
Fucking chin.
I want to see highlights.
Show him all fucking day long.
I will sit.
I used to watch sports center back when I had the time.
I'd watch it like three times in a fucking row.
I didn't give a shit.
Same jokes,
same fucking clips,
all of that.
I loved it.
These fucking idiots sitting there talking and talking and talking.
I wouldn't,
I should talk,
right?
I do a fucking podcast by myself.
Um,
so then I turned the fucking channel.
I'm like,
all right.
They got like 50 to ESPN.
So I go up to ESPN two.
There's two other jerk off sitting there talking,
talking,
talking.
And they show in the scores and all of this type of shit.
And for the life of me,
I haven't seen it.
I heard what happened.
I heard they let the,
let the pitcher stay in and then he walked the fucking guy.
Then there was a double blah blah,
blah,
blah.
And then there was a play at third and the fucking guy,
you know,
they looked at each other then right.
Throws the ball and the guy who fucking takes off,
it's a close play at the plate.
The throws little.
I've yet to see it.
I think it's worth.
Um,
so anyways,
so I don't really know.
Uh,
I don't know what happened.
All of that that I know is cause actually not cause the ESPN.
It's cause I talked to Paul version of this morning,
who by the way,
is really excited that the mets lost,
I've found during the series that he fucking,
he hates the mets.
He hates the mets fans.
Don't let them say anything differently.
Don't let them try to be a class act.
I'm telling you,
they'll run the running joke on the tour was a Paul Versey wants no joy in
queens
cause we were all sitting there like,
I'm a fucking,
you know,
red sox fan.
I shouldn't like any team from New York,
but I don't give a fuck.
Right.
It's a mess.
You know,
they haven't won it since 86.
Fuck it.
I don't care if they win it.
Um,
so I want,
I wanted to see,
I basically,
I wanted to see a seven game series is what I wanted to see.
And uh,
put first,
very silently rooting very hard against the mets and he wouldn't admit it and he
just,
no,
I don't,
I don't care.
You know,
I just want,
I just want to see a good series and that he would get,
he would get just a little too excited when Casey would be coming back.
So,
um,
and he was,
I'm just sitting here fucking babbling.
Uh,
I did Miss Halloween this year was the first time I have not been at my house
during Halloween.
Um,
which I'm actually happy about it cause I told you where I live,
I live in this weird area where it's like if you go a little,
if you go to the right,
it gets really nice.
If you go to the left,
there's like a check cashing place,
like a block away,
you know what I mean?
And I'm sort of in the middle.
So during Halloween I get everything from little snot nose rich kids too.
Like what I had like a year ago where this fucking like,
I dunno,
37 year old dude showed it.
He looked like a fucking homeless Jim Croce.
He just fucking showed up,
right.
Big fucking mustache,
Tom Selleck style.
And it was just standing there and I'm just opening the door.
Okay.
Oh I know.
I,
he had some kids with them and they all left and he had a bag too and he held
the bag out and I just went really?
And he just goes,
yes,
I go really?
Or something like that.
Seriously.
It just goes yes.
And I just fucking gave,
what was I going to do?
That was Joe Good in Chicago.
It's like I got to give it to him.
He knows where the fuck I live.
Right.
That's the thing.
He can't fuck people over on Halloween.
They know what you live.
Okay.
Did they get to do something?
They're going to walk down your fucking thing.
They're going to fucking punch your mailbox and pulled a little flag off of it.
You know,
Yank some fucking,
I dunno,
plant out of the ground,
which I don't give a shit.
Right.
If it's not fucking making me any food,
what do I need it for?
Well,
because they exhale oxygen.
We get it.
So anyways,
um,
okay.
Dude,
I,
I've completely shot from that tour.
I'm so fucking exhausted.
Um,
and it isn't from the shows.
The shows were great.
The people were great,
the venues were great,
but,
um,
my fucking drink every single night for fucking two weeks.
And um,
yeah,
every night I was like,
I can't do what I can't do it.
And that was the joke.
The joke started to become before we shelf,
we would just be going like,
all right man,
tonight we're just going home,
going home early,
which is fucking getting eight hours work out.
Right.
Maybe find a spa,
we'll take a steam,
have a nice fucking healthy breakfasts.
Everybody's nodding.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And then fucking somebody finishes their set and they just got the devil in
their eye when they come off.
And then they would look at me and I would just start laughing.
And the next thing you know,
we go out again.
So we're in Chicago.
My Pie dog town Chicago is
a badge of mustaches.
Chicago is actually,
I didn't see a lot of them.
Michigan Avenue with all those shops.
20 Harry Carey restaurants,
which was the original.
Um,
so anyways,
we ended up going out one night.
MMM.
I'm trying to,
I'm trying to piece this together.
This is the drunkest I've been in like fucking 10 years.
We went out to this,
this,
this bar called the Liar's club and it was like a bar that basically a bunch of
hung out at and we fucking get in there and I don't plan on doing any fucking
damage whatsoever.
Right.
Friend of mine lives in town,
she's a photographer.
She came down to take some pictures,
right?
She brings her crew of people.
We go out and just fucking get into the bar
and I dunno,
I dunno what happened.
They fucking go,
what kind of music do you like?
And I said,
why like eight and Sagel.
How about ACDC?
Right.
And they just played like all this shit.
You never fucking here all this shit.
You're never here.
Everybody was playing.
She shook me all night.
Although somebody did play,
you shook me all night long.
Uh,
they played like kicked in the teeth,
down payment,
blues,
um,
houses on fire.
They point shit off.
Powerage flick of the switch,
you know,
side to a highway to hell dude.
And me and Bart,
nick,
we're going fucking nuts.
Like for Czi was an angel that night.
He barely dragged.
He just said he wanted to go home.
He was just sitting there and like,
at one point barnick you know who's like the size of like fucking Cam Neely,
right?
He's fucking doing the Angus,
you know,
Chuck Berry thing going across the bar.
People go and fucking nuts and everybody just kept buying shots and like an
asshole.
I just kept doing them.
I think I threw down like nine or 10 shots while I was drinking whiskey.
So I was like chasing whiskey shots with whiskey and um,
you know,
you wouldn't think that you could go out on a dance floor and dance to a AC DC.
But God dammit,
I did it.
Yeah.
Oh,
and did I pay for it?
I fucking paid for it.
And then I,
I,
you know,
by the end of the night,
I,
I vaguely remember leaving the bar.
It might've been the best night of the fucking tour.
We had so much fucking fun.
Versus he actually said,
like,
he was saying that because he wasn't even drinking.
He was going like,
I actually wasn't join you and bart nick putting on a clinic on how to have fun
in a bar.
He was like,
dude,
you guys will go and I don't even remember this.
She goes,
you guys were like headbanging.
He's like,
burn your air drumming on the bar.
And then next thing you know,
me and [inaudible] both out on the dance floor dancing to ACDC,
right?
This stupid disco ball going around us.
It was like if it was a movie,
it would have been like a verse.
He was saying.
It would have been like the montage scene of when me and Joe becomes best
friends before,
like we fucking a
for something.
Whatever it happens,
sends it,
you know,
what do you remember the naked gun?
You remember the naked gun when,
uh,
Leslie Nielsen and Priscilla Presley or doing all this shit,
running down the beach,
coming out of platoon,
laughing their asses off.
It was basically that.
It was that,
that's what we did.
And the next day,
like I fucking woke up,
you know,
still in my clothes,
in my bed and like I had all these plans.
I'm in Chicago,
I'm in one of the greatest cities in the country.
And I had all these plans of what I was going to do at,
I swear to God,
like I couldn't get out of bed.
I couldn't get out of bed till like fucking three in the afternoon.
I was like,
what?
I'm a fucking idiot.
And then at five o'clock I went down,
I went downstairs and,
uh,
I tried to get something to eat and I was no wait.
And he came up to my room
for his,
he came up to my room and we would just sit and have fucking watching TV.
And he was just laughing at how fucking just beat up Ho us,
you know,
of course he felt great because he was a fucking angel at night.
And I,
um,
we ended up watching something on TV,
one of the sickest stories ever.
And we're like,
dude,
this has to be a fucking movie.
And,
uh,
of course in the end they,
they,
they said that they were going to turn into movie was basically about this guy,
right?
It was this fucking show about serial killers.
So of course we're going to watch it all right?
And I'm sitting there eating a fucking burger,
you know,
just trying to,
Greece always fucking offsets the fucking alcohol.
It's awful.
I'm out of shape again guys.
Just one I'm trying to say.
Um,
so we'll watching this thing about fucking serial killers and the whole time
that talking about this,
this drug dealer kid and well like kind of fucked is this getting,
they keep showing this serial killer guy.
It's like does in the show in the drug dealer,
older,
you know,
and not in jail and all that shit going,
what the fuck happened?
You know,
just the way they put it together,
it was a riveting,
you know,
like what the fuck is going on here?
So basically what happened was there was this kid,
right?
He played football,
they called them the assassin because every game he ever played,
he took somebody out,
right?
Was it the assassin?
Was that Jack Tatum check Tatum and I forget what it was,
something like assassin.
So
he fucking uh,
and just movie star good looks all right.
And he's The star of the football team and the lady sitting there interviewing
them going as he's walking through round is high school going like,
so you were,
uh,
you were basically a legend here.
And he goes,
yeah,
I was,
he wasn't being arrogant.
He said,
yeah,
he goes,
they retired my jersey,
they had like pictures of me up on the wall and all that,
blah,
blah.
All the women loved him.
I mean,
this guy was just like,
it was,
he,
he looked like a movie star in his life was a movie.
So he's Big Achilles heel was,
he didn't have money and he wanted to keep up with the rich kids.
So he started dealing drugs and he ended up being really good at it.
And by the time he was like 20 years old,
this fucking guy was making like $1 million a year.
Crushing it.
Right?
He's got a fake,
you know,
wall in his walk walking closet where he's got another room where he's keeping
all the money in a,
he's thrown all these fucking crazy parties and it almost seemed like this
American greed type story as opposed to this serial killer thing.
And they keep going back to this serial kill,
a fucking piece of shit.
Who's killing these girls?
These teenage girls?
So long story short,
he's laying in bed one night and he's just thinking,
I got to get out of this life.
I'm so sick of looking over my shoulder.
I can't do this anymore.
How am I going to get out of his butt?
He's addicted to the money.
He's addicted to the life and all of that type of stuff.
And he has this rattling on the door and I'm thinking,
oh fuck,
it's the serial killer.
And he obviously fought the guy in one.
What the fuck happens,
right?
All of a sudden the door fucking blasts open and all these fucking was,
is it the ATF that shows up when you get busted as a drug dealer now?
Who was that?
Alcohol.
Tobacco,
firearms.
I don't know what the fuck it is.
So anyways,
they fucking come.
FDA Food,
Drug Administration,
the uh,
transit Chicago Transit Authority.
I don't what the fuck it is.
Whatever the fuck that thing is.
They come fucking blast and through the door run up,
you know,
a bunch of guys with the fucking minor helmets on with the fucking ooze east
from a Steven Seagal movie.
Go get on a graph.
You fucking look at me,
upload your fucking head off.
And the whole thing was over and he disgraced his family name and they never
said it,
but I imagine they probably took his fucking pictures down off of the high
school and all of that type of shit,
you know,
did some Oj Shit,
right?
Take all his trophies and all that fucking shit.
So it's over.
Right.
So then he's sitting in jail,
um,
and they tried to get him to flip and this is kids,
just some fucking kid from the suburbs,
right?
So I'm thinking,
well,
he's out.
He must eradicate somebody out so he doesn't rat anybody out.
He's like,
I'm not telling on anybody.
So then they're like,
I will fuck you.
So now you're not going to help us out.
We're going to fucking give you,
you know,
the full extent of the law.
We're going to prosecute you.
So they gave him 10 years,
the guy gets 10 years.
He's in like a minimum security cause you know,
he didn't really have any violent past or anything.
He was just getting people addicted to drugs.
That's all he was doing.
So his dad is devastated and all that shit and he goes to jail.
And uh,
meanwhile the serial killer guys out there killing these girls.
So I'm thinking,
what the fuck went in?
They keep going to commercial meat.
He looked and he said to go and how to fuck?
Are they going to tie this fucking thing together?
So long story short,
um,
they ended up catching the serial killer guy.
Uh,
I forget how we fucked up,
but they ended up catching him in one of those things where you seem like
relieved and all of that type of shit.
And uh,
but he had this thing where he wouldn't admit to all of them.
And if he came at him,
he would just clam up and wouldn't say shit.
So he ends up going to jail for like either one or two murders for life.
He's never fucking getting out.
So meanwhile there's all these parents whose daughters were killed by this guy
and they don't know where they are and all,
they just wanted us to body,
they want fucking closure.
And these parents are just tortured by this fucking thing.
All right?
So they're trying to figure out,
because he won't talk to them,
he won't tell him anything,
and he's also in denial and he keeps going like,
actually I didn't kill him and blah blah blah blah blah.
And then one day be like,
oh,
I did and I blacked out.
I don't remember.
Like the guy was,
he's a fucking creepy God damn mess.
Right?
So they ended up coming up with this idea that they need a charismatic person to
talk to this,
to befriend this serial killer,
gained the guys trust.
And maybe he'll tell them where like the bodies are and that type of shit.
So they go to this fucking dude,
Captain America,
you know,
the football player,
the movie star looking guy who fucked his whole life up cause he got involved in
drugs,
right?
And they approach him to go from his minimum security to go into a maximum
security prison with his murderers,
rapists,
animals,
fucking maniacs.
Right.
And um,
you know,
to go in there and they said,
if you give,
if you get this information out,
we'll take your sentence and we'll just wipe out.
The rest of it will set you free.
He'd already done like three,
four years.
So meanwhile,
Captain America's Dad had a series of strokes,
you know,
and was basically gonna die and he had to go see him.
I mean,
it's like a fucking movie.
So he goes,
all right,
fuck it.
I'll,
I'll do it,
but I want it in writing that you're definitely going to let me go.
So they say,
yeah,
so they go out,
right?
He goes,
they go,
here's the deal.
We don't want you to approach him for at least six months because he's very
cagey in,
if you fucking,
you know,
come out the guy the wrong way.
He just fucking walls himself off and that's it.
All right,
so this kid comes wall,
he goes,
then he goes,
fine,
cool.
And he walks in there,
he's like,
I don't have six months.
By Dad's going to die within the first two months.
Two,
I'm sorry,
first two hours he goes into the fucking jail
and he fucking,
uh,
on purpose accidentally bumps into the guy and then he immediately apologizes.
He goes,
Oh,
I'm sorry about that buddy.
I didn't see it standing there.
Hey,
he goes,
I'm new here.
Do you know where the library is?
And the guy tells him where the library is.
And he goes,
thanks man.
Uh,
you know,
and he said something to the effect of a,
yeah,
you're a good guide.
Gives him a little slap on the shoulder.
That's it.
It goes to the fucking library.
And they set it up where his fucking,
his cell was right across the hall from the other guy.
And he says to them,
he goes,
hey man,
he runs into him again.
Hey,
wait,
he stay in Blah Blah.
It goes on.
It's crazy,
man.
You were right across.
And he said,
it's good to be with a good guy like you,
blah,
right across from each other.
And he goes,
uh,
so then fucking the serial killer guy one day he goes,
hey,
you want to get lunch with me and my friends?
And at this point me and [inaudible] were fucking laughing our balls off going
like this kind of social shit happens in prison.
Okay,
y'all are some friends of mine,
uh,
going to have some other murderers and serial killers.
We're going to get some,
uh,
maybe get some,
you know,
[inaudible] a fucking rapper or something.
You want to come down,
just kind of hang out,
meet you down the commissary.
You always think it's all just getting shanked and try not to get raped,
right?
So he goes,
yeah,
cool.
So long story,
he gains this guy's fucking confidence.
And one time he actually goes in and he sees the guy,
he's got a map with all these red dots on it and all that shit and he's trying
to get to it and blah,
blah blah.
So the guy starts opening up any finally ends up telling him this fucking
stories,
um,
of all the women that he killed and all of that shit.
And uh,
in sort of kind of mentioned the,
gave him like sort of enough information about where the bodies were and the
captain America guy kind of fucked up because once he got the information,
he thought he had enough information to find all the bodies and get himself out
of prison and he just couldn't have all,
wait,
I forgot the best part.
I'm sorry.
It's gonna be like a Tarantino movie.
Now we're going to jump backwards.
Another way he gained the guy's confidence was one day they was sitting in the
TV room watching TV.
He sit next to this guy and this big fucking giant dude just gets up and turns
the channel
without talking to anybody.
And as he turns to channel the serial killer,
who was unlike a meek little guy and he just kind of went,
he just sort of said out loud to nobody was like,
Hey,
I was watching that like powerlessly really fucking weird psycho thing.
And the fucking captain America Dude walked up to the big dude and knocked him
out,
just beat the guy's ass,
hit him with an upper cut fucking forearm shiver and just sent this guy flying
through some chairs and then they stuck them in the hall.
That's what happened.
And then when he fucking comes out,
tell me,
it doesn't sound like a fucking,
I almost don't even believe it.
So that's when he gained the guy's conference.
That's when the dude told him.
And his second,
he tells him this dude,
Captain America couldn't hold it in anymore.
And he goes to do you know what?
You're a sick fucking piece of shit,
blah,
blah.
And flipped out on him.
And then the God,
the CEO kill just backed up and he goes,
he goes,
who sent you?
And he goes,
so and so sent you,
right?
And he named the prosecutor,
and then he just fucking disappeared and the map disappeared too.
So then it's like they didn't get the map.
So there was a thing,
we don't know where the fucking bodies still are,
blah,
blah.
But you got him to admit to these fucking murderers.
So we know that the women are least dead.
The blobby basically in the end,
he did enough where he got out.
Um,
and the whole time we were watching this fucking thing,
we would just go like,
this is a,
this is a fucking movie.
And I guarantee you when they do the fucking movie,
they don't even need to add any mustard to it.
But I guarantee you in the movie,
he won't flip out in the end,
you know,
or free flips out.
But then he somehow,
and then that'll be the last little kick kickup like,
oh no,
they didn't find the map in the movie.
He'll find the map and then the parents will actually get closure button real
life.
You know,
it's not a fucking moving in suck spot.
Isn't that unbelievable?
That like,
uh,
it's so fucking nuts.
Like,
at one point they were visiting his old house and he showed,
he goes,
yeah,
he used to live here.
I used to live here and all these cars.
I threw like a fucking 20 kegger here one night and he goes up into the room and
he shows the secret place where his safe is.
Um,
and you know,
when it was Fort Knox fucking things,
it's just,
I dunno man,
it was fucking,
uh,
an incredible story.
Whatever,
whatever.
I know half of them fucking glorifying God damn drug dealer.
Right?
Isn't that what I'm doing?
Um,
and then in the end,
I know you guys wanted a happy ending.
There wasn't a happy ending because he fucking,
he kind of screwed it up in the end,
but they still let him go though.
Just sort of odd.
Right.
You know what,
this is weird and uncomfortable to watch it this point,
you know,
all these videos they show where there's cops beating up black dudes and all
that type of stuff.
You know,
it's really weird is to watch white kids fucking with cops.
Like I saw one kid was doing this thing where he was drinking a beer where you
weren't supposed to drink a beer.
He did like a magic trick and the cop was,
you can't drink here.
He keeps fucking drink,
keeps drinking.
Then he ends up putting it in the bag and then the fucking bottle disappears.
He was like a magician and it's just like,
you know,
that may be missed the Chappelle show,
cause he would have done a sketch about that.
And then when it showed the black guy trying to do the same thing where he would
get like a third into the trick and the fucking bottle would be smashed over his
head.
Um,
I dunno.
And I usually don't go for that whole fucking,
you know,
if this person does this,
but if that person does that,
I mean,
after seeing some of those videos,
and I'm not saying all cops are bad,
you know,
it's like comedians.
You know,
that we're not all hacks.
We don't all have lamp shades on our heads.
We're not all on offstage and have to be the center of attention.
However,
when people think that about it,
I don't about comics,
I don't sit there scratching my head head wondering where that stereotype came
from.
You know what I mean?
That's my only thing with groups of people is like,
you know,
when you're talking about the stereotype,
gee,
people,
it would really help someone who's not in your stereotype.
If you,
if you at least acknowledged where it came from.
Like me,
German,
Irish.
So I get Nazi alcoholic,
a fucking lunatic,
right?
Or whatever,
whatever all of it is potato eat and jackass.
Um,
mass murder in psycho.
Now do I like hearing that shit?
I mean,
I guess I don't give a fuck,
but you know,
I,
you know,
it's easy for me to say I don't give a fuck cause it doesn't affect my life.
I don't walk into a job interview and they go look at this fucking Nazi Red Eddy
current.
We're not hiring you.
I guess then it would bug me more.
All right.
You know what?
Fuck that whole point.
I guess I need to listen to people,
but at some point,
you know what I mean?
It was like we have to like nine 11 when they were doing like at the airport
where they were like anybody even remotely look Middle Eastern,
they would just fucking,
you know,
giving him the fucking,
uh,
they giving him the business and then people were getting mad and it's just
like,
are you even going to address?
Yeah,
what the fuck happened?
You're going to act like you don't know where this is coming from.
Yeah.
3000 people just fucking died.
That was a joke.
I was doing my act.
I was like,
you know what?
In fucking 18 redheads flew to fucking bill planes into the World Trade Center
and knock them down and I went to the airport.
Yeah.
I wouldn't like be and Frist every time,
but I wouldn't be sitting there going,
I know where it's coming from and at some level,
as much as it would be fucking annoying me that those airport comes with
treating me like that just because of the way that I looked.
At some point I would address the 18 redheads that fucked it up for me.
Fucked it up for me.
Right.
Does that make any sense?
Probably does it.
All right,
let's do some reads for this week everybody.
Oh Shit.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody stop shaving with old razor.
It's gross.
Why are you torturing yourself with a gross old blade week after week?
Probably cause you don't want to shell out 20 bucks for a pack of new ones.
That would be our guests.
Dollar Shave club.com has revolutionized the way men shave with dollar shave
club.
You can shave with a fresh blade as often as you want because they deliver a
whole sleeve of amazing raises for just a few bucks a month.
The raises us so good.
Millions of guys have joined.
Even the billion dollar Razor Corporation cunts are freaking out,
but instead of lowering their blow to prices that trying to fool you into
milking the same blade for an entire month.
And you know what?
That's gross.
They've priced gouge just for long enough.
They've hacked up our faces.
You know,
I'll kind of made us hack our faces just because their prices are so big or so
high,
I should say.
Never go back to squeezing weeks and weeks of shaves out of disgusting rusty
blade again,
just joined dollar shave club and use a fresh blade whenever you want.
It feels amazing and it's a third of the price.
Join the millions of others,
the millions and millions of fans of others who have figured out the smarter way
to shave.
Joined Dollar Shave club now by going to dollar shave club.com/birth that's
dollar shave club.com/bar doe shave club.com/barb oh shit.
Here we go about Bait Bait me,
undies,
me on d,
drying out all the clams.
Boudou do,
do me undies me undies.
Harass.
Looks like a ham.
Keeps her Twat all nice and dry,
nothing dripping down on her fucking thighs.
They also make them for a bunch of guys.
If you go to their websites,
you can look,
oh yeah,
nice.
Often under where it gets shipped.
Bulls now it treats them equal.
Yay.
All right,
me undies.
We all know how sexy confidence can be and that confidence comes from being
comfortable.
But how great can you feel if your underwear is wrinkling and writing up?
Yank me undies gets it.
And that's why they've created the world's most comfortable underwear for
regular people.
Cause you know people in the Illuminati,
their balls must just be hovering right for a daily of confidence.
No modal is pronounced modal.
I don't understand why every week,
why they won't fucking show me where the accent is.
[inaudible] put in quotes all lower case m o h Dash Dal modal.
So I'm going to say me undies is made from modal a fairy test twice as soft as
cotton.
That's twice as soft as whatever underwear you're wearing right now.
Unless you're in the Illuminati sitting there with you,
goat head,
getting blown by someone wearing a fucking badger costume.
That's the great thing about being an Illuminati,
right?
Every six weeks it's Halloween.
When you meet under that mountain me and he says tons of colors and styles and
the only place to get matching pairs for men and women,
they even release a new design every month.
I wear whatever free pair they give me and my balls have never complained,
never complained.
Plus we all know that paying for shipping sucks so me,
and he says,
remove that from the equation.
All orders in the U S and Canada ship for free.
Me undies even has a money back guarantee.
If you know love your first pair,
you get to keep it for free.
You literally have nothing to lose other than the free time you'd spent,
you know,
ordering the shit.
There's always something that loose.
Come on me on this.
You know,
I know it.
Don't play dumb with us.
All right?
To sweeten the deals,
me undies,
to sweeten the deal,
me undies is offering you 20% off your first order.
At [inaudible] dot com slash burn that's a special offer for just my listeners
and whoever else they advertise with.
Make sure you go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird and get 20% off your first
order.
And so that they know that we sent you.
What am I got left here?
All right,
we're going to do two and two.
All right.
There's the first two.
All right,
let's get back to why did you conk out on me?
Why did the Internet conk out on me?
How dare you?
Um,
and now this won't move.
Why wouldn't you move?
I'm doing what I'm supposed to do.
This is how you drag something.
All right,
what do I want to talk about?
Okay.
Or The Bruins.
Hey,
are we go bro,
it's,
here we go.
Bob.
Bob's six O in one.
There's six [inaudible] one.
Basically,
you know what happened?
Not only did they start to get to know each other as players,
I stopped watching them and ever since I haven't been watching,
they've been winning.
Um,
we've gone six oh one one.
The only blemish is when we played the Philadelphia of fly.
Yeah.
They came back in fucking tied it up and then they closed Zuru one fucking
overtime.
But other than that,
six Oh one one which you look at that and all dawn Sweeney who I was,
I said at the beginning of the year,
I'm like,
this guy,
the moves this fucking guy made.
All right,
this guy is either going to be
the next bill Belicheck or he's going to be fucking run out of town because this
guy went all in.
Um,
I,
it's just every fucking thing seems to be falling in place.
I know it's really early.
It would be ridiculous for me to get overly excited about this because when they
are over all in three,
I didn't freak out.
You know,
I was like,
they look in competitive,
they just keep fucking up a little bit about halfway through the game.
Then it became the third period now that kind of nailing it down.
So hopefully this is what they're going to be doing.
Um,
but now you know what,
maybe he's more like the Theo Epstein.
I have no idea.
All I know is that we're competitive.
And I was sitting there and looking like,
we're,
we are,
we're going to lose to the fucking Canadians every game again this year.
And,
uh,
all of a sudden now,
you know,
who knows?
Who knows?
We'll see what happens,
right?
Lou Cheech got his first goal for the fucking kings.
Still bugs me to see him in that uniform.
Um,
but we got a,
we got the Dallas Stars tomorrow night.
Dallas stars,
Jamie,
Ben,
Tyler Sagan,
Patrick's shap dude.
How many fucking like former Bruins and certainly Blackhawks a plane on number
one lines around the fucking league.
Look,
oh,
look at fucking Winnipeg with Blake.
We
right Blake Wheeler up there in Winnipeg.
We've got Tyler Sagan and fucking,
uh,
Dallas.
I guess Lou isn't playing on the number one line.
Izzy.
No,
I don't think he is,
but you know what?
That's the greatest thing about going to daily face off my favorite fucking
website.
Now.
You know,
and they don't,
they don't pay me to advertise for the love of fucking Christ.
Bill.
Can you learn how to drag a God damn window here?
All right.
And they also had,
I didn't realize that fucking Dallas.
Oh,
says Jason spits up from fucking Ottawa is this second line center.
Who Knew?
Who knew that?
I didn't know that.
Did you know that they one fucking team was I just talking about,
do you remember all the kinks?
The Los Angeles Kings Cla cuts.
Where the fuck Outta here we go.
Line combinations.
He is.
He's firstline.
Left wing with Jeff Canada and Tyler to Foley.
Oh,
they broke up that seventies.
Like who would have thought they got COPD guitars?
The center on the second one right now you're like Jesus Bill,
how much hockey are you watching?
I'm not,
I'm not.
I go,
Gee,
I just go to daily face off and you look,
you click on line combinations and you can do it.
Jesus.
How fucking deeper they their first lines.
Lucita Carter and to Foley.
This second line is Pearson,
Copa and Dustin Brown.
Nobody watched the king.
I actually liked the kinks.
Um,
unfucking believable,
do anything that makes me happy about seeing the king's is loaded is it makes
me,
it gives me hope that the Canadians will not win a cup again this year even
though they're playing fucking great.
Um,
but anyways,
so get the fucking pro it came right back around
and hung in there and I got all those games tapes,
so I got to watch him and I'm ridiculously excited to watch
the Dallas Stars game because,
uh,
they're fucking,
you know,
they're one of the best teams.
All of a sudden.
I've always been a fan of green and white Kumanti.
I'm a Celtics fan.
Right.
Um,
so anyways,
let me,
uh,
let me plow ahead here.
Another great thing that I did while I was out in Chicago is I went to arguably
the greatest drum shop in the country,
uh,
fixed drum shop.
And um,
it is just basically giant.
It's a combination drum shop and like studio space.
And I lost track.
I think there's like four floors to it.
And it almost looked like what it used to be is you know like the one of those
places you just storage space,
you know all those things are really weird.
Like the way they set them up and as those narrow hallways and you walk down
them,
there's all of that type of stuff.
So he kept all the rooms and he just sort of combined rooms and put in windows
so you could see through and he has like just this symbol room we just had like
fucking any,
he has like total anal,
like he has every fucking high hat you could think of and he has them in
alphabetical order.
So I don't know all the drum names,
but he starts with like DW and then it ends with Yamaha.
Every fucking kind you could possibly ever fucking want the remote,
the remote cabled ones,
everyone you can think of.
He had this dww pedal that I had never even fucking seen before.
They look like a piece of jewelry,
but I in glass he had another area where it was just all a all acoustic drums.
Then he had this whole area that was all a electronic drums
he had upstairs.
He had these two monster fucking kits,
like a Terry Terry Bozzio type shit.
I went over there with a friend of mine.
He let her play on and let me play on it.
It was just,
it was fucking insane,
was fucking insane.
And um,
and I went into one of his drum rooms.
It's nice and clean.
The drums were all tuned up.
They sounded fucking great.
And what killed me is I could have been going down there every fucking day
playing drums when I was in Chicago instead of being laid up fucking hell.
I go,
I got so drunk at the Liar's club with,
and if you think I'm not going back there again and doing nine shots and
dancing,
the ACDC,
it's over.
Like I tell you right now,
fixed drum shop and fucking lives club.
I'm,
I'm hitting those every time I go to town.
Um,
all little next time I'm going to bring the lovely Nia,
you know,
uh,
Chicago is a,
um,
that's a,
see I got all kinds of family out there and you know,
one of the big things,
all the men on both sides of my families would always take their wives down to
Michigan Avenue,
buy shoes or whatever,
like throughout all of the last century.
So,
uh,
that's something that I have to do at some point.
I gotta take,
I gotta take me it down there and buy or something.
But um,
I could not have had a better time than I have to tell you right now.
If you were fucking drummer,
I don't give a fuck where you live.
If you're anywhere,
they're in the Midwest.
If you're in fucking de Moines,
I don't want to hear your bitching about the fucking,
the ride.
Like if you're going to make a major purchase,
if you're going to go buy a bunch of new symbols and all of that type of shit,
I'm telling you,
getting your fucking car drive to Chicago,
go to Vicks.
And I'm telling you,
the guy,
he has everything he had Zildjian had Sabian it pastes pipe pasty.
Pasty.
Why we say that?
Mine only had fucking,
he had an all every fucking high had just,
it was insane.
It was fucking,
it was actually like,
and he was going over,
he had a percussion room.
He was,
he was going over the whole fucking thing.
It was like,
it was like sensory overload.
I almost had to try to be like,
he had like a whole fucking all,
all these snares.
This whole room was just all snare drums.
Hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of fucking it.
The amount of money this guy has invested in just the functions to be carrying
that,
that amount of inventory and other cool thing he had,
he had a whole tabletop,
this giant table,
almost like an island that you'd have in like a big kitchen.
The whole,
the whole tabletop.
The surface was made out of that material.
That's a practice pad.
So like literally like 20 drummers could stand around it and I'll be just trying
out sticks.
And that was a course in the stick from,
I can't even like the whole fucking thing was just,
it was just from top to bottom.
It was mostly the same fucking place I've ever been to.
And I was just like,
hey man,
I wanted to play,
you know,
if I want to,
how much do you for studio time,
he's like,
Hey,
like 15 bucks for an hour.
I can go play in a kit,
you know,
while I'm on the fucking road.
That would have been the greatest thing ever.
So that's,
that's my one regret is that I didn't do that three days in a row and get three
hours better on drums or who's kidding who I probably had gone there for too.
You gotta you gotta do at least two,
right?
The first hours practicing all the shit you suck at.
And then the second hour is just playing into all your favorite songs.
Fantasizing that you're in the bed.
I don't think that's weird.
I think that's normal for me to do.
Pushing 50 years of age.
So anyway,
so I got the big Philly Gig,
the big Philly gig coming up this weekend and a Friday night.
And um,
I was going to be me,
Paul Versey and Joe Matter Reece,
Joe Matter,
Reese Philly native and um,
we're going to be coming in there.
So I've been asking the good people of Philly where I should go to get my
fucking cheese steak,
you know,
cause tourists like me,
uh,
go down to genomes and the other fucking place,
whatever they are.
So I've been getting all these ideas from people and the overwhelming winner.
All right,
this is like an election.
So you get to know who's winning and if you guys think I'm making a mistake,
he got to send me a tweet.
The overwhelming winner as far as,
um,
not going to those two places is,
is John's roast pork and Philly nine.
All right?
Now everybody you'd fill either went like nuts,
like yes,
I should say people from Philly listening to this either went like psych,
then I'm going there or then I'm going to get a bunch.
Dot.
I'll fucking go there and play soccer.
So overrated.
I went dead and we fucking dry.
So John's roast pork,
Philly.
I mean that sounds delicious.
So I think that that's where I'm going to go.
That's where I'm going to go after the show.
I'm going to go over there.
I'm going to stand in fucking line.
As of right now,
unless somebody tells me,
unless enough people tell me differently,
that's where the fuck I'm going.
Um,
that's where the after party is going to be.
I'm going to go out and get a fucking cheese steak and you know what?
I can't fucking wait.
That's going to be great.
I just fast forward in my life.
Um,
so anyways,
but like I said,
I'm going to try to be a good boy here.
This whole week I'm going to be working out and doing all that type of shit.
I got to get my ass back in shape.
I put it on probably like seven or eight pounds over two weeks,
maybe not that much of weight.
It just feels like I did.
But you know what I'm going to while I'm in town and for a good four or five
days before I have to go back out again and I'm just going to eat perfectly and
work out this what the fuck I'm going to do.
That's one I'm going do.
And uh,
I think just from just literally not drinking at this point,
uh,
that alone will be enough for me to drop a couple this week.
So if I drop a good for,
you know,
three,
four before I do,
uh,
Madison Square Garden when I should be happy.
Right.
Um,
all right,
so there you go.
So that's the,
uh,
oh.
Did anybody see that fucking giant saints game?
Did you see the giant Saints Games when I was fucking insane games ever seen in
my life?
One quarterback throws for seven drew Brees,
Eli throws for fucking six.
Did you just fucking,
you want to see it?
You don't want,
every time I watched the giant says something that reminds me,
not every time,
but a lot of times it reminds me of losing Superbowls to them.
That fucking drive that they had the football gods love Eli.
I don't ever want to see that guy again in the playoffs.
He fucking comes down the field,
right?
Dead.
They're threatened.
They're down by what were they down?
But they have down by 14 at that.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's like 42 28 nobody had even attempted a fucking field goal at that point.
I believe so.
Probably hadn't punted either.
So they fucking,
uh,
whatever they call a pass play,
he drops back to pass.
Somebody comes right up the middle fucking drills a guy,
he fumbles the ball.
Saints recover.
There's like 13 minutes left at 12 left.
It's not the nail in the coffin,
but like if the saints drive down and fucking score a touchdown or even kick a
fucking field goal,
the three scores up with probably nine minutes left.
They are ridiculously comfortable at that point.
All right.
The defense would probably be the little deflated because they sense it to,
the saints will be on their toes,
you know,
healthy.
That's just a game changer.
Right?
Football,
gods step in
football,
gods step in once again.
And they called some ticky tack Horse Shit.
Fucking a defensive holding right on the saints,
which gives the fucking uh,
giants the ball back and keeps the drive going.
Gives them like a fucking first down.
They get all the way down to the end there on the goal line.
Eli goes back to pass here,
comes to fucking rush and he's rolling out and they should have sacked them,
but they didn't.
These rolling out and I know it's going to happen.
He's going to throw the ball and somehow it's going to land in some giant,
giant hands.
So he throws the ball back across his body running right,
throws it back,
left with barely anything on it.
Classic Brett Farve six interception,
game throw throws the fucking thing.
It's going to be a pick.
But the guy in the sates,
ms times is jump,
gets hit by another St,
lands on his fucking head and gets a concussion and this fucking duck just lands
into the hands of a giant for a touchdown.
I've never seen a guy,
the the horse shoe that is up to this guy's fucking ass.
I just,
I do like that.
I was like that.
That right there.
If we played them again,
that's how we will lose,
will lose to them just like that.
Exactly.
To a fucking T.
I don't know what it is.
He hated.
That guy has the fucking magic and there's nothing too,
now that I'm saying this and being a whiny cunt fucking Patriot fan,
that guy also made some some fucking sick ass throws.
He's definitely,
I'm,
I'm not sure where to go.
I fucking love him.
I think he's the shit,
but I've never seen a guy fuck up so many times and in and does not pay the
price for it.
Maybe I need to watch your more or maybe I'm still just so fucking rattled from
those two fucking,
oh my God.
We love when we were undefeated,
when he threw,
he threw a pick to a Sunday Samuel and hit him in both hands.
The guy just drops it.
Then he throws behind his fucking receiver.
The guy reaches back over the Patriot guys arm and catches it with his hand in
his helmet.
Fucking,
I mean,
just anybody else said be an incomplete pass.
You fucked up as a quarterback or it would be,
it'd be a pick.
I'm telling you,
I,
I've,
I've never fucking seen it.
It's just,
it's insane.
I never want to see that guy.
If we played the giants and the Superbowl this year,
I'm telling you right now,
I'm not going to watch it.
Or I'll watch the first three quarters and then I'm just walking away and I'm
going to stand outside my party and just waiting for the screams of agony.
I know it's going to happen.
When that happens,
I'm just going to fucking,
I'm just going to walk away when to walk away.
I'm not going to watch ESPN for like a month.
The I,
you know,
I might even take a month off from my podcast.
I didn't even want to fucking see it.
I'm telling you this guy,
he sold his soul.
Something happened.
Isn't that right?
Cleo?
Give me,
I can only have buddy get up on the couch.
What did he say to him?
What'd he say?
I want to hear it.
You never do the fucking moment.
I give you that hug.
She does this thing.
Come up.
She gave her a hug.
She goes,
you stink buddy.
You know that I'm going to give you a bass.
You want a bath?
Now there's the look.
Why don't dogs like get baths?
You know what I mean?
They hate the process,
but then afterwards they fucking freak out.
I can't tell if it's because they feel good to,
they just psyched that it's over.
But it's almost like watching a junkie.
Just keep using rather than just going,
if you just go through a little bit of misery,
you know you're going to be all right,
huh?
Wow.
All right,
let's read some letters.
Clearly you want to chime in on some of these?
All right.
Cross country lady.
Um,
and it may can get knee up here.
She hasn't done the podcast in a minute.
Hang on one second.
Hold on.
Well,
no such luck.
I thought she was downstairs.
Where is she clear?
All right.
Cross country lady a bill.
I'm a 25 year old girl.
You're a woman,
you're a lady.
Um,
pretty responsible and competent and don't wind like some broads over there.
I'm not one of those girls who can say they know how to change a tire,
but I've done enough that I think I could if I had to.
Yeah,
he can change a tire.
You got to change the time,
but she didn't.
Nobody can change a fucking tire with the factory Jack that the Jack handle it.
They give you,
you can't get enough fucking talk unless you just some fucking,
he got those Popeye forearms,
which you really need is you just need a little piece of pipe and you can stick
over.
You know,
you loosen the lug swell,
it's still on the ground.
Denny's.
You go to jack it up,
you sticky spare underneath the tire and then eat the fucking frame in case it
comes crashing down.
That's supposed to save you,
but the fucking thing,
so God damned small now it doesn't matter.
All right?
You take the fucker off.
She put the new one on.
All right.
You put all the fucking lugs on that.
You put in your pocket or in a place he didn't,
none of them rolled away.
And then you lower the car back down and then you tighten and you go,
it's easiest fucking thing ever.
Right.
All right.
That's the attitude,
right?
A on us,
somewhat related,
but unrelated note,
I'm looking to drive across the country now moving to Los Angeles from Rhode
Island.
My parents are cool and trust me,
but they have their concerns about me driving by myself.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You've,
you've seen this great country from all your touring.
I suspect early on in your comedy career there was more driving than flying.
Absolutely.
There was a,
do you have any advice or warnings against me doing so?
I would take a week or so and pick out some different stops.
I drive a 2003 black Volvo station wagon.
It's ready to go.
So my,
what are your thoughts?
Uh,
ps,
thanks for checking in on us on Thursday.
It really means a lot.
Um,
all right.
What would my advice be?
Uh,
my advice,
my advice would actually be to maybe do it with somebody else just because,
um,
especially depends on where you're staying.
You know,
as a woman going out there by yourself,
I would definitely stay at nice hotels,
enough underground parking,
uh,
you know,
just really well lit places.
Don't do what I did where I'd fuck it.
I drove across country in about two and a half days,
one time for my team,
my big square,
1990s TV in the back and I would just pull up to shitty hotels and I would just
sleep in the car cause I didn't want to drag all my shit out of the car into the
thing.
So I just slept there.
Like what fucking idiot?
Someone who sort of broke the window.
By the time I figured up,
realize what was going on,
my throat would have been slipped,
so I would,
I would do it with somebody else.
Um,
if you're going to go during the wintertime,
you want to get south as quick as you can.
Um,
maybe go across the 48.
Nina,
you want to come on the podcast?
Oh,
you eat breakfast.
Can you say hello to everybody?
All right.
Um,
so I would maybe do the 40 as opposed to the 70.
70 is beautiful when you drive across.
Uh,
I believe that I won.
It goes,
they'll actually go south of Pittsburgh.
But you go through,
um,
like I actually,
my favorite part of the 70s actually when you first pick it up,
I set the 15,
the 15 goes up and meets the 70 from the west.
Well,
why don't you take a fucking map out going through Utah.
Um,
wait,
I got to reread it.
You in Los Angeles?
Yeah.
So if you take the 70 across,
going through Utah,
going through Vegas,
going through the rocky mountains is amazing tunnel that you drive through.
Um,
as you get out towards grand junction and all of that,
I will tell you what is a motherfucker is after a,
I mean,
you got to do the thing where you,
you're,
you go through St Louis.
You know,
when you see the arch,
that's the shit.
Um,
and it's cool,
right?
Until you get to Kansas City,
stop at Kansas City,
get yourself some barbecue and then just fucking settle in because Kansas is a
motherfucker.
Um,
that's a motherfucker trying to get through that thing.
Uh,
although,
you know,
if the Jayhawks have a game,
I'd stop baby.
I,
yeah,
if he figured out shit that you want to do the way you could have a great time,
but I gotta be honest with you,
a few of my sister or my,
my daughter or whatever,
I would not want you doing it by yourself.
Um,
but if you are going to do it by yourself,
just make sure you stay in safe places.
Keep your head on a fucking swivel.
And I would also,
uh,
the second you get tired,
pull over.
I mean,
get to your destination.
Don't do the dumb shit that I did.
Well,
you're almost like hallucinating.
I got a buddy of mine,
a comedian told me his story.
He's the one that cured me of it.
He was fucking driving to the airport,
nod,
nod like early in the morning and next thing he wrote,
he woke up,
he was laying in a field,
he got thrown from the fucking car and somehow just landed in the field and was
okay.
And uh,
he wasn't wearing a seatbelt obviously,
by the way.
Did you guys see that kid out here in Los Angeles?
It's a poor kid.
Like 20 years old was driving lost control of his car.
The thing was rolling.
He got rejected out of the car and you know those signs on the freeway that the
trucks,
that 18 wheelers can drive underneath without hitting.
He went up,
he hit that thing and landed.
You know,
sometimes they have like a little walkway up there.
His body landed up there.
Um,
so I would say be careful.
Definitely be careful.
Um,
what the fuck is all the rest of the questions here
for this week?
That's what I would say.
Oh,
look who's here.
It's decided to show up.
Cleo for the love of fucking Christ.
Are you going to do that every,
every week?
I can't get to the podcast without the thing you just love on plugging.
Shit.
Don't yet.
All right.
Come in.
And he helped me with these last few,
uh,
these last few questions.
I don't know what just happened to him.
I had a bunch of questions and they all went away.
It live or ease content?
Yeah.
Oh,
I don't even know when that one was from.
All right.
Here we go.
Royals.
You don't want to talk sports to you.
Can you grab another microphone though?
Yeah.
Hang on.
Let's see here.
You can plug it in here.
Can you grab a microphone and I'll plug it in?
I think it's somewhere in my bag.
Either that,
yeah,
we'll probably have to share one.
Sorry.
Hang on.
Plugging in.
All right.
What the magic of the pause button.
Here we go.
All right.
Yeah,
we're going to talk sports with you.
Oh,
Goodie.
The royals.
Where are they from?
Cincinnati.
Nope.
Wait,
good guests.
So it's one of those cities,
one of those be so called b-level cities.
I don't know.
Wait,
wait.
Uh,
no,
no.
I don't know.
They have great barbecue,
Kansas City Ram,
Billy Bass.
I know you're touring and you didn't get to see much baseball,
but I just want to say how much
I like Harold Reynolds.
You know how Ron and joy,
it's a huge difference having a guy who can explain baseball.
I know baseball but uh,
it's the insight you want to hear.
This was a great world series.
Don't know what the ratings were,
but this was the best baseball I've seen in a while.
Despite the fact that the mets were lucky to be there based on their record and
slow start to the season of what the fuck does that mean?
What do mean lucky to be there?
You don't get lucky getting in the world series.
You won the game.
She had to win.
The royals played really excited.
Baseball hits are more fun than home runs any day.
Thanks for the podcast already.
Cause he's just saying he likes Harold Reynolds.
That's really not a question.
Um,
no.
I was like,
you know,
it was really cool was of course you know this to see George Brett excited like
a fan when he saw them all run out,
you know the Great George Brett last go came the closest to hitting 400.
Okay.
You had 400,
like through August almost.
He ended up with at three 90.
I'm all right.
How old were you drama.
Here we go.
Nina,
you are home for Halloween.
Yes.
I was uh,
Bill
really bringing it this week.
You got to really bring it.
You didn't get any breakfast.
Yes,
I was.
Halloween is a date in October.
Yes it is.
All right,
Bill,
I'll cut right to the chase.
I was at a Halloween party and naturally tons of girls were dressed scantily
clad.
My girlfriend's costume though a though a bit revealing was extremely tasteful
compared to other brands.
So I see this dude taking pictures of girls asses and just being a creep about
it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
So I look at him as if to say,
what the fuck are you doing?
He just walked away a couple minutes later.
I see him snapping a picture that was framing my girlfriend's tits,
lb.
It,
they were covered and not hanging out.
It was a creek still a creep move.
Yeah.
So I stepped in front of him and confronted him.
Yup.
He said it's a party.
Everyone's,
everyone takes pictures.
A couple people looked at me funny like I was an over protective Douche.
What's nothing is I opened my mouth before it even involved my girlfriend.
Did I do something wrong?
Of course not.
Well and that's the thing about it.
It's like I feel like it's women can say over and over again,
don't take pictures of me,
you know,
stop leering at me.
Stop being a fucking disgusting,
perverted creep.
But it's going to take guys like you and other guys to say to other guys like
that's not cool.
That's not taking pictures of these girls unless they were like posing for
pictures for you.
Right.
I think I just of my girlfriend don't do that.
I don't care if it's a party.
I don't care.
That happens to me.
One time I went to some bar or club or something and I was dancing with my
girlfriends and this dude came and was like trying to video the entire thing of
us dancing together and I was like,
I just stopped and I put my hand in front of his face and I was like,
don't do that.
He was like,
Ooh,
fruity know about my,
everyone's just like taking pictures.
It's cool,
it's cool.
I said,
no,
it's not cool.
You're not allowed to take pictures of me.
Stop taking pictures of me.
And then finally he just kind of like turned away and I'm sure he'd go when your
own problem.
And he actually is a lot,
but you still just tell him,
even though he allowed,
he's allowed you if you want,
you're in public,
you're considered in public and it's,
it's on you,
but it doesn't make it okay.
It's the new cell phone Aaronia it,
it's,
there's no rule that says you're allowed to just take me out.
There's no rules.
Say we can't,
do we need to talk about,
sorry,
I knocked the plug out.
We're back here.
Here's the thing,
like with cell phones now,
like all of that type,
so you can tell somebody not to do it,
but they can't be prosecuted or anything for doing it.
Once you're out in public,
uh,
you're considered in public and people can take pictures of you.
Hmm.
Like the Paparazzi,
they just follow famous people around.
They take fucking pictures of him,
everything.
They can't go like into their house or go onto their property.
Then they're considered trespassing.
But the second you walk out there,
we as my question,
yeah.
I don't think,
obviously I don't think that someone should fucking take pictures.
That's definitely creepy.
But as far as the leering thing goes,
do you think women have any responsibility as far as if you're going to go out
there and dress suggestively aren't,
do they have any responsibility?
I think that if you go out and you're dressed in a revealing way,
I think yes,
of course.
Naturally people are going to look at you,
but it doesn't give anybody the right to say nasty things to you or to touch you
or to think that they just have,
I'm not talking about touching.
I'm just saying somebody staring at you.
See I knew you were going to get mad.
No,
I knew you were gonna get mad.
I'm just saying like it's,
it's like you do if you don't want that to happen to you.
Right.
And this is Kinda what,
whenever the fuck I want to wear,
that's the bottom line.
I can walk down the street,
make wearing a fucking suit,
made out a dollar bills and then when I get hit over the head and mugged,
I'm going to be like,
I should be allowed to blah blah blah.
There's like the way nobody who wished the world could be and the way it really
is.
I agree.
But I don't think that anyone should feel like they have access to you on those
levels just because of what you're wearing.
It's still not right.
Absolutely.
It's not right.
But my fucking name,
the same thing.
I know,
but my thing is,
is you know that there's creeps out there,
you know,
that does animals out there.
Why would you put yourself in the crosshairs of them?
Because I,
well,
because it's not about them.
It's about what has about you or the personal you hair.
Yeah.
And so if I want to go out and wear something sexy cause I'm feeling myself,
then I'll go out and wear something sexy.
And I would expect that people would look at me.
Sure.
But what I expect them to start like taking pictures and shit.
Nah,
I'm not saying pictures.
I'm saying the leering thing like as a guy at all,
you're going to get looks on the guy's side of it is when a woman shows up with
their tits hanging out.
Okay.
And you look at her tits and then she gets mad.
We're always like,
well fucking put them away.
And then it's always like,
well I should have a right to have my tits out there,
my tits,
you know?
And then we get yelled at like where these fucking lunatics.
And it's almost like,
like that input in policing that's like entrapment.
Well,
I think there's,
well first of all,
no one's fucking thinking about you.
All right.
You're not fucking Marion Barry.
This is an entrapment.
Okay.
So yes,
look,
not the ceviche manning their leg the entire time.
It's like I start feeling fucking creeped out and weirded out and unsafe.
So have your look and keep it moving.
Okay.
So that's definitely fair.
Have your look and keep it moving.
I love it.
That's the rule.
So let me ask you this,
but don't try to invade my space and try to get into my head and all that kind
of shit.
Like don't do that.
Have your look.
Keep it moving.
All right,
here's my question for you.
What's the difference?
What's the time we will put a shot clock on this.
You know,
in the NBA he got a 24 second shot clock.
The difference between having your look and lyric,
how many seconds before you're a shot clock violation.
He had turned over the ball.
Um,
I think anything beyond,
okay,
five seconds.
Five seconds is a great look.
Yeah,
five seconds.
Should do it.
The old up and down.
Hmm.
Nice.
Maybe a little smile.
Keep it moving.
All right.
Now that I took less than five seconds to even describe all that.
Well,
so I think five.
You want to have five seconds.
I'll show you five seconds.
He's looking in one,
two,
three,
four,
five.
So someone can look at you that long.
Yeah,
that's good.
That's all right.
Yeah,
that's fine.
That's fine.
You're a hard shit.
All right.
Five seconds.
Any ladies out there if you want to,
you want to add some time to that?
You want to shave some off there?
That is the kind of thing that the guys though,
cause listen,
sometimes you know what's the worst thing is when you're not a fucking pervert,
but the woman's gorgeous and she's wearing something so revealing and then she
comes at you like you're a fucking creep and you just like,
you're wearing a cat soup.
Okay.
Like what am I supposed,
I'm not supposed to fucking look.
Okay.
That's all right.
That sounds,
yeah,
you can.
I,
it's like I keep saying look and keep it moving,
but that's it.
I know what I have to be this whole fucking thing where you're like staring and
panting and by staring you're trying to get my attention so that I react.
It's like if you're going to stare then I catch you staring.
Just sorry.
It's for stair and you just,
you,
you look beautiful.
Thank you.
Moving on.
There you go.
And then what if he tries to talk to you?
I mean he,
you know,
what's he supposed to do?
You'll look good.
He wants to fucking,
uh,
you know,
thank you.
Keep it moving.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah,
you can't,
well what if he wants to a sheet?
It what if,
what if?
What if you were single?
I mean you have one.
Well,
it depends.
If I'm interested in like continuing the conversation or whatever,
then yes,
let's continue the conversation.
But in all aspects you got to like wait for like the opening to appear.
You can't just force the opening.
That sounds gross.
Yeah.
Don't know.
We're like door to door salesman,
single guys.
We just,
we have to like fucking just knock on the door.
Yeah.
Are you doing I'll pill.
I really like to have some effects.
Okay,
thank you.
How are you doing?
Yeah,
and that's the thing about it.
It's like guys,
act like,
you know,
it's not like the fucking end of the world.
Like,
you know,
10 seconds later you're talking,
I'm looking at somebody else.
So what is the big deal about moving on?
If there's not like the person's saying in your music fucking break,
why can't I can't get mad at end of this five second look,
keep it moving.
If I give me a look like I want to keep talking,
these are really basic ideas,
you know what I mean?
It is.
It's really,
it's really basic.
It's all right,
but what was the talk to you that they'll continue talking to you.
Oh,
thank you so much.
Old are,
are you here with a friend or not?
Boom.
Let me ask you this.
Have you ever been out with a front who's wearing something so revealing and
they're getting so much of that attention?
They're complaining about it.
Have you ever said to him like,
well,
maybe you should've put the girls away a little more.
You know,
maybe you should have brought the garage door down a little bit more.
No,
you've never said that.
I've never said that to any of my girlfriends.
Have you ever thought it even felt it?
No.
You've never had a roommate or a girlfriend just show up and be like,
oh my God,
her who ha is almost peaking out from underneath that dress.
This is what I'll tell you.
It's gonna be a rough one.
Like,
you know all of these dogs.
You never think that I had to be honest with you though.
I don't think that most of my girlfriend's dress revealingly okay.
So have you seen,
have you seen somebody that you don't know show up at a club.
Okay.
With like,
you know,
body paint on and a pair of pastries and just go like,
am I at carnival?
Like what is she going,
you know what I'm talking about?
I'm just asking do women also look at the woman yes.
And look at her and be like,
what is that idiot doing?
Um,
yeah,
probably.
I think that's a yes,
but for some reason you're not going to give it to me cause I'm a guy.
Well No,
I don't think that's it.
I think there's definitely been times where you're just like,
really girl.
Really?
Okay.
All right.
And that's,
that's,
that's about it from my girl.
Really.
Okay.
That's fine.
That's not a good answer.
Like if I see a girl wearing shorts that are like,
like denim shorts that are basically fitting you like underwear.
I feel like that's a little extra to have your ass hanging out.
But if a girl wants that walk around with her ass hanging out,
I,
it's like I'm not,
it doesn't trip me out.
But I do personally feel like it's a little bit much.
And why is that?
And I'm also getting older so I'm getting a little bit more conservative cause I
don't need to see your ass cheeks or I don't need to see that.
Yeah,
there's not,
a lot of times I will contribute,
it's not bore me.
It's not even necessarily for guys.
It's for her.
So despite how I might do this,
by the way,
I might feel about how she's dressed.
That is her decision be dressed,
how she's dressed and guess what?
It doesn't ruin my whole day and it doesn't send me into this tailspin of like,
oh my God,
I don't understand.
He's girls are walking around half naked and no,
I'm not supposed to look like Wham,
wham,
five seconds.
Keep it moving.
No boy,
here's my thing.
Do you understand how fucking ridiculous it is to walk down the street with your
ass hanging out?
I do understand how ridiculous.
I do think it's ridiculous and I think it's too much,
but again,
it's not my fucking thing to get upset about what somebody else is doing.
You know?
It's funny,
it's not my business when I drive down the street being it asthma and if a woman
has her ass hanging out,
I'm just like,
I got like a free show.
Yes,
exactly.
There's that classic thing.
There's that classic thing where like cow guys can't do that.
There's nothing we could do like physically like that that makes you guys almost
crash.
Your car is a hacky joke,
but if you're walking down the street with a half our nutbag hanging out,
you'd be like,
yeah,
cause that's not random.
I know we're animal sex.
Say a woman's ass can be sexy.
Her breasts,
her legs or whole body is just like curvy and delicious and the whole bit,
it's like a bag hanging out,
discuss thing and you want to call the police.
If it was a car,
like the woman's like a Lamborghini or a Ferrari or a Porsche.
When we're looking at pictures,
do you know like have you ever heard of a woman like going into a place and
exposing her genitals to like a room full of men running out?
As creepy as that is,
I flashers are the funniest fucking thing ever.
To me.
The fact that the,
you know the classic one with the fucking wingtip shoes,
the dark socks and just the raincoat on and you just throw open your fucking
coat is showing your flacid Dick or whatever to me and then people are
horrified.
Like the reaction that you get dramatic.
It's fucking,
that's the funny thing about it is that the,
you would think that you did doing something cause in the end you wanted to get
a positive reaction but to fucking throw it open and people were literally
repulse.
Like when you do that,
looking at your naked body,
the fact that they get off on that is fucking hilarious to me.
It's so gross.
It's just a dick.
It's just that there's a dick outside,
you know,
wants to be free now.
Now it doesn't,
it doesn't want to be pray.
It doesn't need to be free.
Keep it tucks away and your little underpants,
you know,
I can understand most fetishes that was at the,
for the life of me,
I don't get what,
what are you doing?
What are you doing?
And then you do that and then what you jerk off to the screams still ringing.
I Dunno.
It's just,
I don't even know if they do it when I was on,
I don't think that they do it.
Like,
I think Hollywood
made it be the raincoat because they couldn't show a dick on film for whatever
reason.
So they just had the guy go like that.
So it would block all of it and you just see his naked legs and you would eat.
It was understood that he was naked.
But I think really it's,
for the most part,
it's probably sweatpants and they'd probably yank 'em down and then they have it
right underneath there.
Can they go?
All right.
Yeah.
Okay.
I remember being in a New York City subway car and this guy started masturbating
in front of me and I ran out and I was pretty much in tears.
It was so upsetting and it was just so,
it's like it's violating,
you know,
to someone staring at you and just being like,
why are you laughing?
It's not funny.
It was really upsetting.
Okay.
See you don't fucking get it.
I know.
I figure you should have laughed at him and pointed right at is well,
yeah,
you gotta go exactly what he wanted.
He wanted to like me to keep like watching it and like,
no,
he wanted you to be fucking shocked.
I would,
I don't know either way either.
Either way was just horrifying.
And it felt like,
it felt terrible.
It was like,
it was,
uh,
a real violation of me,
you know,
like you can't just like see a stranger and just started jerking off.
What the,
take a mental picture,
keep it moving,
get home,
and then rub one out.
Right.
Gentlemen for your dirty studio.
Roach infested apartment.
Well,
why just cause he jerks off from the train.
Doesn't mean it can't be successful.
Nine to five.
I don't really care about his,
his success.
If he feels the need to jerk off and maybe he's one of those guys,
he's like,
we're not a success
failure.
I got to think afterwards,
after you had done doing it,
that gets some point when he'd come home and you're brushing your teeth and you
look yourself in the mirror,
you gotta be like,
Wow,
I'm that guy.
The jerks off to people on the trade.
I'm sure they hate themselves and they should
look at Clio half on the bed,
half off.
And I'm sitting over here like,
what do you want?
What do you want from me?
All right.
Halloween drama.
Okay.
Yeah.
So getting back to that thing,
he didn't do something wrong.
They have the guy's a fucking creep.
Yeah,
you should definitely like interject when shit like that is going on and let
other men know.
That's not cool.
Alright.
Hologram comedians a breaking bad bill.
Have you heard the comedy club in New York?
Might Showcase Carlin and prior holograms.
Uh,
okay.
I mean I don't,
I don't get that.
That's fucking weird.
That's like a live week to me.
Why?
I don't understand the point of it's so stupid.
Just go home and go home and what it's going to be material you've already seen.
So all you gotta do is you just go home and you just put in the DVD.
I would like to have been there for that Tupac Hologram at Coachella a couple of
years ago.
That would have been interesting.
Only because you know,
you're probably like on a ton of drugs at Coachella and stuff like that.
So you're just like,
like there are all these videos of people like recording it,
you know on their phone and you hear people in the background going,
I knew it and people would be like,
I told you,
I told him like he was actually alive.
And then they're like,
oh no,
no,
it isn't all,
you know what I don't like about it.
What I don't like about it is to pop.
Didn't agree to do the,
he didn't agree on the money.
Who owns the rights to his likeness?
Mom Probably.
And she probably gave it the,
okay,
can I tell you?
So really,
what does that the afterschool special version of entertainment,
I'll tell you right now,
I bet I'm going right now in,
in,
in the future.
In the future,
I bet all dead celebrities like,
like fucking scumbag people in this business will own their likeness.
They'll somehow trick the fucking next to f whoever into fucking selling the
rights to them.
And they'll still have these people touring and they'll put together like these,
these hologram fantasy teams and Pete and they'll make money off of these people
and their loved ones won't get any of the cash.
That's what I'm guessing that's going to be the lawsuit and the next 20 years
that a dead fucking George Carlin went on tour and grows $20 million of
something like that and none of his next to Ken got any money and then some
fucking little piece of shit.
We'll have no comment.
Yeah.
You don't think so.
That's what I think about that.
That doesn't happen clean.
Of course it will.
There are they already fucking,
they'd been used.
They started using them in and commercials.
They had like a dead John Wayne selling like fucking an Xbox or something.
It's fucking ridiculous.
All right.
Cross country onto them.
Here we go.
Cross country.
Oh,
I already did that one.
this lady said really quickly,
uh,
she was saying she's 25 year old girl and she's uh,
going to be moving across the country.
She's driving La to a Los Angeles.
She's driving the car by herself.
Obviously get the whole fucking thing to be careful.
Yeah,
right.
That's what I was saying.
I said she should do it with somebody else.
I'm going to tell me I should be.
It shouldn't be able to handle it.
She'll be,
she'll be all right.
Just be careful.
Yeah.
Does it make sure that car is running perfectly and you know,
make sure you don't stop at any sketchy fucking motels and always makes me think
of your man about,
um,
murderers.
Buffet.
What did you call it?
Serial killer.
Busted her killer buffet.
A motel.
They just locked down.
Well,
your door opens up to the parking lot.
The buyer.
Yeah.
Syrah.
Kill a buffet.
I'm killing this guy and killing that guy.
That one's all right.
Yeah.
You stayed in the fucking hotel from a no country for old men.
All right.
Legal Zoom.
Everybody got to do a couple of,
uh,
you won't listen to me.
Do the reads and then sign off.
Sure.
All right.
Jesus,
uh,
legal zoom,
everybody somewhere along the line.
Annoyed,
piss you off.
And then the flasher thing,
you should,
did I?
No,
I dunno.
It just in general just think go on just an in general annoyance of me.
Yup.
Ben,
please really read your,
read your ads.
I come back off a two week tour conquering goddamn hero.
I was so happy and within 24 fucking hours,
you're already sick of me.
That's what you're saying.
Unfuckable you know what,
Nia,
if you ever,
if you ever leave me for the rest of my life and I'm just going to be that guy.
I'm going to have dogs.
I'm up dogs and I'm going to go down to a massage parlor ever day.
Get one rubbed out and I'm going to be good for the rest of the day.
Dogs and the fucking NHL package.
Tell my jokes.
That's it.
And your lawyer goes to call me.
I'll be,
what does she,
what does she want?
What does all sweetie cakes want to talk about that scene that
you'd dump?
Baller,
oatmeals and all meals at sugar corn smacks.
Now it's steel cutting for Nola that hasn't dried banana and if for some fucking
reason.
All right,
legal zoom.
You don't like bananas?
I don't like the texture.
I hate when you say that.
It's always a food that I like and then you'd go,
why don't you like it?
Did the,
I don't like the texture.
That's a narcissist that I can't even not like a certain food and get offended
by it.
Like what do you care?
No,
no words.
I know like I don't like always me.
Why Bill?
I like texture.
I'm says that it's a legitimate thing.
I don't like the texture of banana.
It feels weird in my mouth.
It's not so fun to fucking piece of food.
Okay.
Texture can refer to things that aren't just like furniture,
furniture.
I just hated it.
They don't like the texture like you some food critic.
Just be happy.
God made it and eat it.
Good legal zone to say that.
Say that Sunday,
Sunday afternoon.
Yeah.
You're going to go.
You go meet God.
He tells me,
you know,
it's my had a great time.
Thankfully.
By the way,
can you work in the banana thing?
I didn't like the texture.
This isn't like a human being.
I'm a love God.
Now Mikey throwing a bunch of different combinations.
Natural.
So what's like your weed man?
We'd as oh yeah.
Well that's a good thing.
It's good to see you.
Yeah,
you too.
It is good to see you.
It's like to be home.
Yeah.
Jesus.
Uh,
you shouldn't have to choose a random lawyer who charges expensive hourly rates
when you need legal help.
You know,
like if she saw somebody jerking off to you and the train,
but the legal system is so complicated.
What other choice do you have when you need help in your business?
What's Your Business?
So you want to protect your family.
Start with legal zone.
They make it easy for people for more than a decade.
They've provided a way for regular people like you and me to conveniently
navigate the legal system,
Legos,
ohms,
not a law firm.
And that's how they provide such great value.
They don't rely on charging you by the hour,
like those lawyer bastards.
Instead,
you'll get a transparent pricing and customer reviews so you know exactly what
you're getting upfront.
If you need help with your incorporations LLCs,
trademarks,
last wills,
living trusts,
Nini,
and more legal zoom to smart choice.
They got the right people on hand to answer your questions and if you need legal
advice,
well God damn it.
Their network of independent attorneys can provide the straight forward tough
talk to turn this town around,
the guidance you need.
Most states don't let legal hurdles become an excuse.
Go to legalzoom.com today to start building your own future,
the right way to save even more and to burn the referral box at checkout.
That's dot com Promo Code Berg,
legalzoom.com Promo Code [inaudible].
All right,
stamps.com getting your mail and shipping done.
Could see my,
I just delivered that like some weird actor for me to do this.
Again,
getting your mailing and shipping done can seem like a no,
no one situation going to the post office takes up valuable time leasing a
postage meter,
expensive with multiyear commitments and hidden fees.
Luckily I know a better way.
This is when the sun comes up.
Stamps dot comm buy and print official US postage for any letter or package
right from your desk using your own computer at bread,
even get special postage discounts.
She can't find it.
The post office she skied save at least 50% kid compared to using a postage
meter and you avoid all those time consuming trips to the post office I use and
highly recommend staff calm right now.
Sign up for our staff Dotcom and use my last name,
birth for this special four week trial bonus plus a $210 bonus offer including
postage and a digital stay up scale.
Don't wait.
Go to us to ask.com.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com and
Tupper
staff side comment.
Tupper all right.
I like how you shout into a microphone,
which is designed to project your voice.
So I know,
I know.
I actually,
I pulled my,
my head away.
I'm a master at using the microphone.
If you actually took the time to watch one of my sets one time.
Oh please.
And you watch TV,
you watch the ebb and flow of the,
I bring that crowd up.
I pushed him away.
Yeah,
it's a real journey.
It is that you take my Dick Jokes,
have three acts to them.
You know what,
Nia,
I was so excited to see you and I still am and for you to sit here coming back
and yet I'm not.
I'm not feeling the love from you.
You still look cute.
That notion.
No thank you.
No,
I'm excited to have you back.
You've been gone for two weeks.
That's great.
That's your home.
You sound like you're reading a statement from look for an incorporation.
We are excited to have him back.
I was gone for two weeks,
be back.
We still haven't gotten all the information so we can't comment on anything else
at this time.
Right,
exactly.
You'll get that goddamn dog that thinks slept eight hours last night.
I literally walked around the block,
even food and it is just out like a light.
It's like now people,
it's,
it's on his dog bed.
Three quarter of his dog.
His body is on the dog bed and then like it's head and neck is off.
Okay.
Looks like it passed out.
He's like,
it's fading.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Thank you everybody for listening and uh,
Hey Nia,
you're a huge a cheese steak fan,
right?
I love cheese.
I love cheese steak.
I don't like,
I felt like you were leering at it.
Just look at the sandwich and keep it moving.
Keep it moving.
I love cheese steaks.
It's my favorite in the whole world is a Philly cheese steak.
Do you have to say Philly cheese steak or can you just say cheese steak when
you're in Philly cheesesteak.
But everywhere else they've built,
when you're in fucking France,
you just ordered onion soup,
you know,
go.
Okay,
can I get French onion soup?
They're like,
well,
you're in France,
you fucking idiot.
So everything here is going to be French onion soup.
I guess that's true.
Okay.
Um,
everyone's telling me to go to John's roast pork in it.
Doesn't that just sound good?
The name?
Oh,
it's a,
it's a place to eat.
Yeah,
because one of the two.
What are the two touristy places?
It's Geno's and what else?
Oh,
I forget.
Gino and a Rabinowitz's.
Yup.
Chinos.
Oh wait,
Phil too.
They're right next to each other,
right?
Yeah.
Hang on.
Hang on
Geno's steaks and uh,
and then the other one,
I don't know how to look it up and I can't do it with one fucking aunt evil.
But even those were good last time in version went though.
We,
we got,
we both got stood in line.
He stood in one.
I stood in the other,
we got one of each,
cut them in half and then,
oh did like a,
I'd say stats.
Yeah.
Alright.
Top 10 spots.
They are you,
are you willing to reveal which one you liked better?
Um,
all pats.
All right,
so one of them had a better cheese.
I can never remember this ship.
Do you get or I liked the bread.
Better Whiz.
I don't like Wiz.
I like real cheese.
Me Too.
I like the real cheese.
The cop fucking good.
Those look,
and this is thanks to you guys.
Go on.
Understand stand out here.
They just don't have good delis.
They can't make good,
it's the dry air or something that can make good bread.
The sandwiches,
the pizza is fucked up.
Got Up as Shami place.
That's supposed to be really good.
And downtown La.
I forget the name of it.
They talked about it on that show.
The comedians.
Oh,
okay.
Josh Gad and I'm fucking brilliant.
Show that I absolutely loved it.
Then I'll bring it back for some fucked up reason.
Yeah,
it sucks.
I love that show.
Listen,
I gotta,
I gotta upload this cause I've got to get on with the day here.
Hour and 25 minutes.
Ah,
cause you stuck around.
All right,
everybody go fuck yourselves.
I'll check it out on Thursday.